I definitely want to start with I think
a lot of people over the last few years
have gotten very comfortable watching
movies at home even on their phone but
the thing I want to point out about this
film is this is a movie you want to see
in a movie theater this is a movie
experience can you sort of both talk
about the fact that you do want to see
this one in the theater
I mean yes I would love for people to
see it in the theater because I think
theatricality is is a is a is a term
that almost transcends theater it's
actually about experience and the the
the the the really incredible benefit of
getting to tour this movie a little bit
to the festivals is that you actually
start to get a sense of what it's like
to watch this with your family to watch
this with your friends and you know it's
it's where I'm selfishly really excited
about it being a Thanksgiving Day movie
because it it fits the it fits the
formula for me as a film lover and
someone who also loved his family
um to like go see it together while
everybody's home you know and it's
because you know the the scope is Big
the emotions are big the performances
are big you know and and it's it's also
kind of answers to me like it
it's not only Giant action movies that
get to have that experience but also
stories that feel big stories that move
us are are also effective in that
environment that communal environment of
film watching so
um yeah to me that's that's why I'm just
I'm so excited for it to be it to be
coming out in theaters
also just feels different it feels
different from you watching it on your
phone on your laptop with screeners or
whatever to actually have it in front of
you to the way that a shot to feel the
planes go near you to sit at the table
with Jesse and Daisy and feel the weight
of that emotion it's all just heightened
when you're in a bigger space with sound
that covers you and I just think that
it's it's going to benefit you to go see
it in theaters I 100 agree
JD I'm always curious about the editing
process because that's where film comes
together and I'm curious how did this
film possibly change in the editing room
in ways you didn't expect
that's a fun question you know the the
trippy thing about devotion was
we we litigated the script so intensely
and prep that once we started shooting
the movie didn't change much
um and that's not always the case but I
was really really blessed with a lot of
a lot of time to prep time to rehearse
with you know the gang and and really
really put every scene to the litmus
test so by the time we came to shoot it
was like oh we've been here before and
neatly by the time it came to cut I'd
really been here before now obviously
you know
you start to suck it in you tighten it
up you know I think the first cut was
like
three hours 45 minutes you know uh just
because you you leave ever I mean you
leave every every stare you leave every
you know longing look all of that stuff
stays when you're still just sort of
seeing it for the first time
um but devotion was really a movie that
was tightened in the edit more than it
was found in the edit
um um which again I really I really owe
to just the amount of time we had to
prep it I think I just want to make sure
for people that are going to watch this
and be like oh my God you had a three
hour 45 minute cut we should say that
that is not a version anyone should see
yeah that is the funny like other side
of the coin of like the director's cut
like please do not watch my director's
cut it's it's terrible right I would be
horrified if that was like released as a
special feature because it would be uh
on unwieldy so I'm way happier with uh
the theatrical theatrical cut than I am
the director's cut so um yeah if you
ever see that run do not watch the
director's cup Christina you have some
great scenes with Jonathan uh and he's
such a great actor I'm just curious uh
both of you are so good together uh what
was it like filming those scenes and
working with someone who clearly is
giving it as all
the dream you you want to be able to
come into this space to tell this story
and know that what it is that you are
giving is being reciprocated
um I think it just makes the
understanding between the two characters
and actors better but also I mean he
comes in already first day just so
prepared he was already Jesse There was
just this matter of well who are these
two people when they're together when no
one else is looking when no one else is
around and so to get into these scenes
with him to be in these spaces with him
Jonathan is so intentional
[Music]
um
it it gave me every bit of uh motivation
that I needed to be able to get in here
and do these scenes with him and
you know be mindful of the emotionality
and be mindful of the intimacy that you
want to be able to show these people
um
it's just you know this this man and
wife and what it is that he's trying to
accomplish
on that note I need to stop I'm just
going to say congrats I really do hope
the films thank you hey thanks Steve
really appreciate it man